ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément loin de paris
mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus se taire ils
ont des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité la
france oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne
voit jamais
aujourd'hui je me rends à carcarès
sainte croix dans les landes
j
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le maire joël aussi
maïs taux va tout va bien ça va bien
mais la moustache drue et l'oeil vif
oui il faut un quand on est à l'appel
est sûr mais je vous appelle monsieur le
maire vous n'êtes plus mr vous n'êtes
pas un homme mais je sais naturellement
que je suis devenu maire de ma commune
et puis président des maires ruraux des
landes parce que pareil je me bats
contre pas pour des valeurs propres à la
ruralité mon nez sainte-croix ici on est
à sainte croix on peut quand même
percevoir quelques signes de
désertification d'abandon de la
substance rural dont l'abandon du
patrimoine rural que vont devenir plein
plein de ferme à lormont qui suis né qui
suis né là donc moi j'ai connu tous à la
vie écuries pour moi faire revivre ce
patrimoine c'est ne pas abandonner le
lien avec l'histoire
cette désertification rurale c'est un
des effets pervers de l'intercommunalité
des communautés de communes de la
concentration des connu j'ai perçu donc
cette rupture avec une civilisation dès
l'âge de 20 ans et quand j'ai vu les
grands seigneurs à bordeaux j'ai vite
perçu que moi il fallait que je revienne
vivre soit ferme familiale
tout ça fait partie d'une globalité donc
perte surtout de milieu agricole
il faudrait que dix ans culteurs
viennent s'installer
donc nous sommes plus en plus de
communes dortoirs comme dans beaucoup
d'endroits dont pertes à près de la vie
associative
il ya des craintes à avoir et c'est pas
commun des communes qui crée du lien
la comédie commune c'est une institution
théocratique les élus qui se soumettent
les élus qui a abandonné un combat pour
les idées parce qu'ils disent c'est le
sens de l'histoire quelque part bien sûr
mais qu'est ce qui va rester tout cela
dans 10 dans 20 ans vous avez constaté
cette accélération depuis une dizaine
des nuits sur tout et je crains qu'on
veuille tout résoudre par des
manipulations numériques
au lieu de revenir vers les habitants et
la pandémie va accélérer cela aussi avec
le télétravail je pense qu'il faut
maintenir quand même des liens sociaux
et humains c'est ça le plus important
parce que parce que d'enseigner et
sociaux il ya toujours des réserves
d'imagination et de création que les
gens peuvent développer mois ce qui
n'est rien pour vous la première facture
entre elles et d'abord entre la ruralité
et les villes oui mais mam
d'urbanisation qui remonte dans la
plusieurs dit voilà depuis dix ans il ya
une fuite en avant et que personne
maîtrise quelque part il faut tout
reprendre à zéro
donc c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
donc vous vous sentez un peu les parents
pauvres
oui de la france les élus ruraux ou
complètement oublié oui oui alors que le
on a souvent le mot patrimoine à la
bouche
voilà vous parlez patrimoine rapidement
ça serait pas mal ou alors pour moi
laïque donc formé à l'école normale
je me suis qu'un battu pour réunir mon
quartier ici autour de la restauration
d'églises qui allait tomber
allez on va aller devant l'église si
vous voulez
après je peux à vous amener à l'âme à la
maison aussi qu'on voudrait voilà un
ancien maçon qui avant-hier qui me
disait il ya de moins en moins de jeunes
qui veulent malgré le matériel qui
veulent continuer le métier masson
malgré les machines et les trouvais
qu'on avait atterri voit la pluie les
machines mais sur ce qu'il faut voter
facilement parce qu'il ya des savoir
faire sur ces vieilles maisons elles
parlent ces bâtisses parle parle
d'elle-même
c'est dommage de d'empiler tous les
jeunes à l'outil se marrer dans les
campagnes comme ici de laisser tout
tomber par terre à tous à l'abandon moi
je trouve que c'est vraiment dommage une
autre fois comment c'était attention
c'est pas pareil non mais les conditions
de vie et de ma soeur à damas en compte
a fait moi j'ai commencé il y avait 14
ans on travaillait jusqu'au samedi soir
on a vécu un dimanche de repos et on
faisait la mer alors que du show de la
mer 75% du travail se faisait à la mer
c'est toujours dur avril
il y avait une ambiance années par une
wii ont cassé la croûte à 9 heures on
allume feu
on avait un kilo de rouge dans le sa
commune un coup c'était comme ça et là
c'est méchant tir en fait des charges et
on mettait le bouquet un holà et le
propriétaire payant pour avoir tous les
artisans
c'est dommage on perd on ça se perd nos
traditions nos valeurs on les perd petit
à petit on se fait bouffer eh bien merci
on va vous laisser travailler
cebu c'est un élu france insoumise bien
sûr et de l'église bien sûr c'est moi
qui m'occupe en fait là aussi la
déchristianisation veut dire qu'à très
peu de gens pour s'occuper patrimoine
aussi donc il faudra que les générations
à venir aussi sera ne compte que est-ce
qu'on laisse tomber un truc comme ça
voilà la question la question sera aussi
bien que c'est là qu'aurait elle est de
quelle époque cette église xiième siècle
elle est en travaux et man magnifique
off et donc des costumes anciens
hollinger me voilà là vous avez des
décors perd 20
mais ça a été restauré ça coûte ça ça
nous a coûté 100 millions de centimes
dont il y en a ailleurs mais les
bâtiments de france nous ont dit stop ça
coûte trop cher on verra plus tard
bon c'est ce qu'on va faire on va faire
la photo puisque c'est comme ça qu'on
conclut chaque fois l'émission
mettez-vous derrière le jeu vous prendre
en photo vous êtes fort en curé
[Musique]